infrastructure the most important things
facing the country in terms of getting
the right infrastructure for the next
generation and I'm delighted to be
playing a role and seeing we've got the
modern infrastructure that we need as a
country was a big decision of yours to
leave labor it's very important that
this commission is independent and being
independent means it needs to have a
head
there's independent too and that's why
I'm taking an independent position
what will your priorities be in this new
role we need to get the transport energy
and housing infrastructure that's going
to see us through the next generation
and it's a very big challenge for us as
a country do you think it's possible to
take the politics from this I think it's
possible to have a very very strong
objective view on infrastructure
requirements obviously if the
politicians that need to take the
decisions government and Parliament need
to take these decisions but it's Britain
it's possible as with the Davis
Commission on airports to bring a strong
objective analysis to underpin decisions
and I think that's for the good of the
country